You can now purchase "Real Vegan Cheese",
which is synthetic, milk-free cheese, created
using strands of human DNA.
Your lips appear red or pink not because the
skin is a different colour, but because the
skin is thinner than normal and you are actually
seeing the underlying blood vessels through
the skin.
It took the inventor of the Rubik's cube a
whole month before he was able to solve the
cube for himself.
Before dummies were invented human corpses
were used for crash tests.
Instead of hiring gardeners Google use 200
goats for mowing the large amount of grass
at their headquarters.
A recent study published in the journal Psychological
Science found that posting an image of a dish
to Instagram before eating it, can make it
taste better.
The "Grey School of Wizardry" in California
is the first wizards school to be officially
recognised as an academic establishment.
In 2005 a man named Ronald MacDonald actually
robbed a Wendy's.
The average human being gets through 900 skins
in a lifetime.
There are more people speaking French in Africa
than in France.
In Japan, Ronald McDonald is known as Donald
McDonald to make pronunciation easier for
the Japanese.
The youngest known person to ever be divorced
was only 10 years old.
To disguise dead passengers during a flight,
British Airways used to give them sunglasses,
a vodka & tonic and a copy of the Daily Mail.
To avoid being caught on film by a speed camera,
you would have to be travelling at 28,000
miles per hour.
Two-thirds of the world's population has never
seen snow.
If melted down for scrap, a bronze medal from
the London 2012 Olympic Games would be worth
less than £3.